the guys were asking me who is exactly
in the wack pack here beetlejuice for
sure
eric the actor
fred the elephant boy ass napkin ed i'm
putting him in the wack pack tan mom
definitely wack pack
hank the angry drunken dwarf wack pack
gary the conqueror he's in the wack pack
of course ham hands bill whack he's in
the wack pack mary in from brooklyn now
i don't remember what i said in the past
here's what i know about marianne from
brooklyn i remember i'm changing it i'm
changing oh really explain please the
voice when she calls in it's like it's
like running nails on a on a chalkboard
and she's such a fan that it's almost
bordering on insanity you know what i
mean so
yes i'm putting her in the wack pack if
she hasn't been in it then she's in it
sour shoes for sure
riley martin of course
bobo
now he was a no
is bobo in the wack pack let me really
think about this i got to make a
decision where is this maniac
you want to be in the wack pack right
well i one time i was teetering on the
edge you guys put me in put me out i
think when i did that walk of shame kind
of uh you know
uh cemented me in i think i don't think
bobo's in the wack pack i gotta i gotta
say i don't think so he's a super fan
yeah
wendy the slow adult is in the webpack
underdog whack pack medicated pete whack
pack yes mark the bagger whack pack yes
asian pete whack pack jeff the vomit guy
definitely wack pack marfan mike whack
pack captain jenks see i don't think
captain jenks is in the wack pack he's a
regular guy who makes good phony phone
calls
right joey boots was not in the wack
pack but high pitch eric is in the wack
pack hey howard can i add one to the
list and i i i would fight really hard
for him and i don't know how he was left
off this list crackhead bob
of course he's wack pack i don't know
who left him off the list that's
insanity he's not alive anymore but he's
definitely wack pack hall of famer i'll
give you a hard one you think lenny
dykstra's wack pack oh
i don't think he's wack no me neither
yeah who i really was you do think he's
whack pack how do you figure nobody
really pays attention to anything lenny
does anymore except for us you know what
i mean like he's now in our universe and
he's he's out there i mean he does
outrageous things i'll even take my
teeth out for you
happy birthday
dear robin not wack pack sorry there it
is there's your list